[Musique]
entretiens politiques avec ghislaine ce
mec est la présidente du pôle écologique
du groupe pôle écologique du conseil
régional qui est donc conseiller
régional et qui soutient yannick jadot
bonjour
avec vous donc de la campagne
présidentielle de la compagne de yannick
jadot peut-être un mot d'abord sur
quelqu'un que vous connaissez bien
puisque c'est la présidente du conseil
régional c'est valérie pécresse est-ce
que vous avez été étonné de sa
candidature étonné de sa victoire à la
primaire ait l'air et est ce que vous
êtes étonnés par la campagne qu'elle
mène
alors non non non pas et n'est pas
étonnée qu'elle est à poser sa
candidature à la présidence de la
république je pense que c'est une femme
qui a de l'ambition et en politique et
heureusement nous avons des femmes qui
ont l'ambition
étonné par contre
on sait pas quelle qu'elle allait
remporter cette primaire il faut dire
que
voilà les femmes les femmes a droit qui
le combat est plus compliqué se penche
pour elle et puis et puis sur
l'accompagnement pas étonné pas étonné
par ce que parce qu'on en fait elle
applique ce qu' elle fait déjà la région
c'est-à-dire beaucoup beaucoup de
communication beaucoup de communication
cl c'est bien faire est là une vraie
stratégie pour cela beaucoup d'affichage
beaucoup de
décisions qui sont prises
simplement pour répondre à des
préoccupations actuelles mais avec un
manque de politique réelle sur le faux
et en l'occurrence
personnellement je suis je serais très
inquiet si ça devait elle qui devait
reporter la présidentielle vous n'êtes
pas de ceux qui disent pas ce qu'on
entend beaucoup ça elle a bien réussi en
ile de france
non mais non alors et pas simplement
parce que je suis une opposition dont
moi je pense réellement que si enfin on
a quand même 4 rapport de la cour
régionale des comptes qui démontre que
aujourd'hui à la bonne question de
valérie pécresse elle n'est pas aussi
elle n'est pas aussi bonne que cela et
je vous invite à les aller consulter
notamment le dernier le dernier rapport
sur la gestion des lycées des montres
aux anglais qu'on a on a deux en tout
cas les proviseurs ont de très grandes
difficultés puisqu'il ya plus de de
soutien en termes de fonctionnement donc
pas d'assurance pas de maintenance et
donc ça devient très très compliqué
c'est à dire que sur le long terme
aujourd'hui on peut se dire et se
targuer à ces magnifiques elle s'est
quasiment 487 millions d'économies sur
sur le fonctionnement c'est ce qui a été
le cas alors qu'on sent monter une crise
sanitaire est en pleine crise économique
on sent aujourd'hui on a des
franciliennes et des franciliennes qui
ont besoin de soutien des dead
alimentaire de construction de logements
dont on fait les économies elle fait des
économies sur le dos des franciliennes
et les franciliens et le patrimoine de
la région est en train de de 2 subie en
fait c'est ces coupes drastiques de
budget donc donc sur le long terme ou
opéra malheureusement
donc vous n'êtes pas de ceux qui disent
'voilà l'ile-de-france est un
laboratoire pour la france veut nous on
est là la campagne de yannick jadot y
eut ces primaires qui sont plutôt bien
déroulées mais on a trouvé quatre
candidats qui étaient pratiquement
égalité le deuxième tour entre yannick
jadot sandrine rousseau était très serré
est-ce que c'était éparpillement ou
fonds d'aidé courant écologique
n'explique pas peut-être la difficulté
que rencontre yannick jadot dans sa
campagne aujourd'hui
alors je ne crois pas moi je crois
réellement que si les résultats et au
rite est si serré c'est parce que nous
avons vraiment pas un programme commun
un projet commun la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique la lutte pour
la justice sociale pour une meilleure
démocratie pour et pour le pacifisme à
celle ce sont les 4 piliers de de
l'écologie politique c'est que le fonds
était là et le petit la différence se
fait sur la personnalité et sur la
proche et la volonté de mettre en place
les mêlées et de cadence et les
les actions à mettre en place donc donc
c'est pour ça que c'était serré
maintenant je crois réellement que nous
partageons tous les mêmes objectifs chez
les écologistes que ce soit chez
génération en génération écologie c'est
un rassemblement que nous avons fait et
donc moi je ne pense pas qu'ils aient
acquis et de 2,2 d'éparpillement au
contraire nous sommes tous derrière
yannick jadot aujourd'hui même si il y à
toujours parfois bien évidemment mais ça
on le voit dans tous les partis
politiques parfois des frictions entre
entre les personnes mais je crois
réellement aujourd'hui que tout le monde
que ce soit delphine batho que ce soit à
qui que ce soit sandrine rousseau enfin
tout le monde est derrière est derrière
du nick shadow la wii c'est plus des
problèmes de personnes voyez vous il ya
quand même des courants écologique un
peu différent en face on est énervé va
peut-être un autre mouvement
gagne quand on regarde au fond l'épreuve
les grandes propositions yannick jadot
on s'aperçoit que celles qui sont
plébiscitées si je peux dire par les
français sont peut-être pas les
propositions essentielles c'est à dire
le bien-être animal qui est une chose
très importante mais qui pourraient être
portées par d'autres candidats recueille
en effet l'assentiment des français le
soutien à l'agriculture bio aussi le bio
de nos cantines également mais sur des
propositions plus plus clivante se dire
la sortie du nucléaire c'est à dire le
vote à saison l'interdiction des
voitures diesel là bas il ya plutôt de
majorité de français qui sont opposés à
ces mesures est-ce que c'est pas des
problèmes que vous rencontrez dans cette
campagne
si si mais ça a toujours été le problème
des écologistes c'est à dire comment
expliquer les choses en fait on sait que
le monde et est pas simple il est
complexe il n'est pas guy nerfs c'est
pas oui ou non il y a toujours des choix
à faire et nous pensons que pour régler
la question du réchauffement climatique
pour aller vers plus de justice sociale
il faut effectivement prendre un certain
nombre de mesures collectivement mais
pour nous c'est redonner du chance en
fait à ce que nous faisons si
aujourd'hui la politique ne sert que à
et j'entendais d'ailleurs
sur le sujet qui disait la droite c'est
la liberté la gauche et l'égalité
moi je ne partage pas son show constat
la droite c'est la liberté
d'entreprendre c'est pas la liberté
manifestement de pouvoir se déplacer
c'est pas là la liberté de culte c'est
pas la liberté de contester c'est la
liberté de pouvoir entreprendre de
pouvoir créer de la valeur de pouvoir
faire du pib de pouvoir faire de la
croissance voilà ce que nous propose
aujourd'hui la droite nous ce que nous
souhaitons c'est ne pas simplement aller
chercher et créer de la richesse et de
toujours plus riches la question c'est
comment redonner du sens comment être
heureux comment construire en fait sa
vie dans un monde qui aujourd'hui
devient de plus en plus difficile à
construire et aux vendus nous pensons
réellement qu'il faut pouvoir donner des
objectifs pouvoir donner des
perspectives pouvoir redonner du sens et
donc il faut faire de la pédagogie parce
que lorsqu'on dit effectivement pas de
nucléaire les gens se disent on va plus
avoir d'électricité mais c'est pas le
cas c'est à dire que on a des scénarios
rte a créé un scénario montrant qu'on
pouvait se passer du nucléaire est
pourquoi nous sommes toujours contre le
nucléaire même si on pourrait penser que
c'est meilleur pour pour le climat
puisque il n'y a pas de co2 c'est parce
que nous prenons deux facteurs un
l'endettement c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui le coût du nucléaire et si
on devait intégrer le coût des
démantèlements est beaucoup plus cher
que le les énergies renouvelables et
puis il ya la question des déchets qui
nous ont barque pendant des siècles et
des siècles des déchets radioactifs est
donc là on touche la question de la
santé donc donc il faut systématiquement
nous puissions faire de la pédagogie et
expliquer pourquoi si collectivement
nous y mettions tous si collectivement
on demande aux grandes entreprises ils
sont souvent les plus polluantes de
pouvoir
voilà agir dans le sens du théma si on
demande aux grandes entreprises de
pouvoir agir dans le sens social c'est à
dire d'arrêter les délocalisations et
bien collectivement nous arrivions à
m'améliorer
très grandement notre vie et puis
surtout assurer une pérennité dans le
temps puisque on sait que la surpêche
climatique va poser de plus en plus de
problèmes quand on dise sortie du
nucléaire dans le pur c'est dans les
vingt ans il s'est passé pas
immédiatement
c'est bien de le préciser qu'ils
procurent des choses souhaitez vous vous
l'avez dit enfin parler de la bretelle à
gauche le mouvement écologique
appartient à la gauche il ya un
éparpillement là aussi on parlait de
parler peut-être l'éparpillement à
l'intérieur du mouvement écologiste ya
un éparpillement de la gauche anne
hidalgo avait proposé des primaires et
yannick jadot comme il est en tête dans
les sondages et ce qu'il n'aurait pas eu
intérêt à y participer et à devenir le
seul candidat ou faut des
sociaux-démocrates et des écolos
en fait nous avons fait notre primaire
et
en 2017 il y avait déjà une cas c'est à
dire que la question pour les
socialistes se poser à savoir comment
nous allons faire pour rassembler
rassembler toute la gauche en 2010 at
yannick jadot alors qu'il avait gagné la
primaire des écologistes puisque dans
les sondages il était il était moins
bien placé il a pris la décision il a
décidé effectivement de suivre benoît
hamon s'en
repaissent thione les citoyens si oui ou
non il fallait il fallait qu'il
abandonne sa sa candidature il y avait
réellement qu'une volonté de pouvoir
faire le rassemblement ça fait 6 %
bah ouais et ça a fait 6 % mais société
je pense que les écologistes ont obtenu
ont tenu leur contrat et beaucoup de
socialistes ont voté pour ma peau au
final
aujourd'hui celle inverse celle inverse
et je crois réellement que le projet
écologiste est beaucoup plus porteur et
fédère beaucoup plus rassemble plus que
le projet socialiste aujourd'hui on va
bien que les socialistes se cherche et
c'est absolument de sauvegarder leur
parti ils ont ils ont raison le
socialisme aaa
a produit son histoire il est des choses
des choses importantes mais mais
l'objectif aujourd'hui c'est vraiment de
créer un modèle pour pour les français
c'est de pouvoir continuer à faire en
sorte que la france puisse être
voilà un pays qui dans les premiers
grandes nations de ce monde et continue
à rayonner comme l'a toujours fait et
l'idée n'est pas simplement de sauver
des des candidatures ou des partis donc
donc je crois aujourd'hui que voilà il
faut il faut il faut raison garder moi
je ne suis pas aujourd'hui très
convaincu du rassemblement on l'a fait
pour les régionales je me rappelle bien
sûr ça ne va pas créer une dynamique
supplémentaire nous avons des programmes
différents nous avons des priorités
différentes des objectifs différents
même si on se retrouve sur un certain
nombre de choses et je crois qu il faut
que ce soit les françaises et les
français qui qui décident de ce qui
pourrait leur semble le plus important
il ya aussi importants ceux ci on va au
delà des présidences et pour les
élections légistatives si iliad exado et
devant lé socialiste comment ça va se
passer vous allez toujours faire des des
alliances avec le ps au moment des
législatives où vous sache accueillera
sur sa manière ça va ça va être l'issue
des discussions que nous pouvons encore
avoir aujourd'hui avec eux
dépendent du positionnement du parti
socialiste aujourd'hui avec la
candidature d'un lindahl galgo une
candidature de christiane taubira
c'est quand une multiplication et un
éparpillement des voix donc je pense
réellement qu'il va falloir
effectivement être en capacité de
pouvoir discuter vous savez nous les
écologistes nous avons rien puisque
malheureusement parce que justement
yannick jadot s'est effacée la dernière
fois nous avons aujourd'hui aucun député
alors nous avons un groupe écologiste
mais pas directement le député europe
ecologie les verts donc pour nous c'est
un enjeu de pouvoir défendre
la biodiversité de défendre le climat de
défendre la justice sociale tout comme
tout comme les autres semblent 2
decelles l'hémicycle de l'assemblée
nationale donc donc eh bien nous verrons
quelle quelle attitude vont prendre nos
partenaires de gauche pour pouvoir
travailler effectivement à à ce que nous
puissions avoir un hémicycle de
l'assemblée nationale qui soit
représentatif des différents corps aux
politiques merci beaucoup disent les
débats lorsqu'on voit le temps qui nous
est imparti juste un dernier mot quand
même moins de 10% pour votre candidat ce
serait un échec
oui je crois absolument pas qui fera
moins 10% réel enjeu
je suis convaincu qu'il fera qui est
rapide et bon on aura l'occasion dès
d'en parler d'ici là il reste encore une
centaine de jours d'ici les élections
présidentielles merci beaucoup j7 ne se
rappelle donc vous êtes la présidence du
pôle écologique de faire du groupe pôle
écologique du conseil régional et vous
soutenez la candidature de yannick jadot
merci
[Musique]